Today's topic Jubilee.
We brought together seven.
Psychics. I am a psychic. I am a psychic.
I am a psychic. I am a psychic. I am a.
Psychic. Y'all are some frauds, but let's carry on.
I am a psychic. I am a psychic.
One is a liar. If the group discovers who the liar is,
they'll split a cash prize. If the liar survives,
he or she wins the entire prize.
So they gotta guess the mole listen, I've seen enough of these videos.
And normally they catch the person. The first two rounds.
If the psychics can't tell who are the psychics
what's.
Everybody's Zodiac sign before you can Capricorn Capricorn.
Who has a website dedicated to their psychic business at the top of it,
it was more of just like seeing who was answering very generically or kind of
piggybacking off of what.
Everyone else was saying. Okay. What makes you a psychic? Like,
what are your gifts?
I have way exorcism.
Also a specialized path, life, medium gym trajectory, bones, medium. Do.
We have any star seats here? Oh, definitely right here.
Somebody who is more involved is going to know what a star seat is.
And so by identifying those that were familiar with that I knew for sure was the
real psychic. Where from <inaudible>. Yeah, I've been to all the galaxies.
I have eight worth marks outta my body. So those are galaxies that you're from.
Anybody else I know about them. I just don't subscribe any.
Friends, sir. I, I.
I, I, it's not something I do.
I was kind of nervous. Cause I was like,
there are so many aspects of how someone comes to be a psychic and then it just,
it was so heavy. There were so many energies.
Anticipation.
I don't know what the right slang would be to use. We had a vampire on stage.
I didn't like her energy. I felt like Rihanna was trying too hard.
Was trying too hard.
I man, my man, if you wasn't trying to look like a slave master,
you actually are a natural dark calling of offenders. <laugh>
it's not kids to keep fried chicken. It's bro fried chicken.
The crazy thing is that girl's definitely a psychic it's what?
The one who just left the piece dress. Mm she's not the mall.
Okay.
He knew that I wrote his name.
So he made sure he wrote mine cuz he was threatened by me.
And that's what I'm used to since I am a light worker and I do everything with a
peer intent and half of these people up here do not do everything with a peer
intent.
She's legit crazy. She's won a hundred percent a psychic. Yeah, listen.
There's general. A little bit of psychopathy that goes psycho.
So I was like, oh wow. Of course the light worker gets shunned off first.
So when you come into your gifts, I was born with.
That born this way. He looks like he does magic magic cars, magic tricks,
magic gathering, magic gathering. Exactly. <laugh> exactly.
So oh saying, um, but also I studied.
So like I will say like I did a lot of studying, so I went to new Orleans.
I learned how to read bones. Does anyone use tools? Yes.
At first I thought that I was gonna be the person that was asking like doing the
most interrogation. But once he started, I was like, great.
Cuz I figured it could work against a person. Are.
We like part-time psychic? Are we full-time full-time.
I work as a Reiki master teacher.
So part of my work is know using my psychic skills of course,
but I don't do ter readings and all that I could, but I don't.
She did, you know, she, she referenced a lot that she did Reiki. So I was like,
you're not really mentioning like other abilities. She just stuck with Reiki.
And I was like any Beverly Hills housewife. Does Reiki.
Do you have a spirit that you contact prior to any sort of activity who you
ancestors?
I go directly to God source creator. Okay. Saint.
Charma, Saint Charma. I do Papa Lega. That's your, my.
Who.
Is it? Get the outta here. Yo, why ask?
Cannot talk about Papa leg, but like that you, yeah, you the one you,
the one you, the one you been to Orleans. Nah, you do all in Papa.
Come on now. Yo don't.
As a patient person.
Don't don't play. Don't play. Don't play. Y'all been oh,
I've been in new Orleans.
So I'm gonna don't don't it's not because you follow a couple of who do, uh,
Instagram pages that you, you opinion. You heard about Papa,
but you don't go to pop, but first outta here.
You got don't don't that doesn't maintenance. So you,
that doesn't necessarily make you a psyche. Okay. And.
How did you come about that family? It was no, no, no, no.
It's my ancestry is very old. We date back in the United States to the,
the 15 hundreds. Okay. Uh, we were,
we were French Protestants and we were known as witch is her BL spell casters.
Got it. Are you a magician? Um, in a sense, yes. I don't do magic tricks.
Black or white. There's no such thing. There's no such thing. Depends.
It's all about intent. It's all about intent. Well, if you violate.
Free will that's black magic. So that, I mean, but call it what you want now.
Do you guys.
Do any like distant work or you just support what people in person? Yeah I do.
Oh yeah. I it's depend. Depends. Right.
I have a few freezer spells at home right now. Oh no. So you,
what do you do after your freezer? He was in the freezer. What do I do after?
I'm not gonna tell you freezer.
This is like people who've been playing D and D for 20 years getting together.
And then you're that one person who's never played. D and D you just listen.
Yeah, my, yes, my level 13 P polite and multi-class to a ranger for two levels.
And as a result,
he's able to get a pet who they then used as a means to start engagements
as he used opportunities of attack. So you think.
You think is the, the go with the frizzy hair?
I don't know who it is. Honestly. All this magic talk is interesting.
Crazy. Yeah. Those find out a freezer.
Spell is a very important aspect because it slows people down.
Those whom would wish negative energy upon new,
you sort of write their name and you freeze them.
You are physically taking their energy and making it small. So they cannot,
they can't get out as easily or rather they will leave you alone quicker.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. That's from, uh, the Maytag tribe.
You know, it's funny.
I remember watching this one guy from English parliament and they have this
thing, like where he, he speaks, the name is MOG. Some MOG. I can't remember,
but he's like, well, there's a, a certain man,
which the young body flowers will engage in.
Reciprocal. As ideas are exchanged,
you can almost feel the palpitation of, uh,
thoughts expressing themselves through the atmosphere.
And as the ecosystem is brightening through enlightenment,
there's a certain air to the T that just, ah, so succulent.
And from there we a new.
Generation, that's basically,
that's basically a Haitian radio talk show just saying
necessary. All the words they want to say, because they're not saying.
They're not saying. No,
what I, what I call what I call?
It's like, you're not saying anything. You just saying big.
He's a character. He does a lot of like magic. I wouldn't do.
I think you can, like you can put blocks on people. I don't think that that is,
that is. And in terms of black or white guy,
I think there's so many I learned in anthropology.
There are so many racial associations with the word that's magic.
Can't stand it. Because when you think of, when you think of black magic,
what you think you think of the bones you,
well, she was so pretty. And when I first saw her, I was like,
I think you're a model, not a psychic.
Cause. Cause psychics are ugliest. Apparently we know, you know why?
Cause uh, witchcraft is a sin and they're UGLi as a sin.
Ugly people would engage in such being.
I noticed she started to piggyback off of what everyone else was saying.
Then it was kind of just like, so what do you actually do? And with her,
everything kept going back to being Reiki, Reiki, Reiki, Reiki, Reiki.
And I thought,
can we just.
Call it now? If everyone feels confident that you've already caught them,
you can end the game. Now raise your hand.
If you have any doubt and would like to continue. So majority wins,
which means the end. If the lights turn green, you voted.
The lighter out. This is definitely gonna be red. 100%.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> who are you picking? Her.
Second one.
Okay. All right. I think it's the guy in the blue. If.
The lights turn red, the liar is still in the box can be blue.
I knew it. I knew the mold was still in here.
Mold, please. That.
Forward. Now I knew it. I knew it too. I felt it. I felt it.
I knew it knew it too. I felt it I'm like psyche.
Did you feel like you knew who the mold was before you got here today? I.
Well, I did divination before I came here and I actually have it written down.
I was looking for the mold to be female around the age, 25, dark hair,
mixed race, brown eyes, hair past her shoulders. Curly.
I have it written down. Can you show us? Yeah, I can.
The only thing is I put straight hair though, actually brown eyes,
female about 25.
Danielle.
So I'm not a psychic because I don't have that clear ability to connect to a
higher consciousness at this time.
Cause I know there's a lot of healing that I need to do in north for that to
open up.
I knew your shoes, its your shoes. I can't explain. They're fly.
They're really nice. But I just, I was just like, this is beautiful,
but this is trying so hard.
That would be if,
even if I was not a psychic and you're telling me that I'm trying too hard to be
a psychic coming from you, bro. You look like you,
you look like an extra from Jeno. What are you talking about?
Yo trying too hard, bro. The brown, you put more to, into your,
your mustache as you did in her whole outfit.
That's a no dude is this fascinating to watch people who are super supposedly
connected to other planes are so much self-awareness they are completely
disconnected from this plane. That's crazy. But again, there's a lot of, uh,
mumbo jumbo, which doctors,
all this other stuff that aren't about what they cling.
So every time I watch these things, I'm like, eh, it's been so commercialized.
I'm not saying it's never true anywhere, but when I see it commercialized,
I never buy into it. It's just,
it's like you have enough E ego to come on a game show to prove that you can
pick out who the Mo is,
but you don't have enough ego to use your skills to enrich yourself to the S
degree. Really? Really? You know what I'm saying?
If you had those abilities,
wouldn't you be using them to predict things that'll make your life
substantially better? Hmm, no, no.
Is this me bro? Well, maybe these people are really good natured.
What do I know? And you're right. Uh,
shout out to Jubilee for exposing psychics because this is the only episode I
ever seen where they didn't get the Mo out. That's hilarious.
<laugh> throw with the psychics. This is actually one of Jubilee's best be
the psychics <laugh> at any rate.
Let know what your best stick in the comments below we want hear from you guys.
I knew it.
I,
I, I.